en un vídeo anterior vimos que cuando el
carbono está unido a cuatro átomos
tenemos una hibridación sp3 con una
geometría tetra erika y tienen un ángulo
digamos ideal ideal de ciento 9.5 grados
verdad y si nos fijamos ahora en el
claro en los carbonos que tiene el éter
no digamos este carbono justamente de
aquí entonces ya no tendremos la misma
geometría verdad la geometría de los
átomos alrededor de este carbono resulta
ser plana muy bien podrías pensar que
toda esta molécula está metida digamos
en el mismo plano muy bien y por
supuesto también podrías pensar que los
ángulos alrededor de este carbono por
ejemplo son de aproximadamente 120
grados verdad idealmente
y justamente este carbono que digamos
subrayado aquí está unido sólo a tres
átomos y tres átomos verdad tenemos un
hidrógeno otro hidrógeno y un carbono
así que esto necesita una hibridación
distinta para cada uno de los carbonos
presentes en esta molécula verdad así
que vamos a empezar con la configuración
electrónica que tenemos por acá verdad
tenemos el estado excitado tenemos
tenemos cuatro electrones de valencia
que están aquí representados ok 1 2 3 y
4 y en el vídeo de la hibridación sp3
tomábamos todos estos 4 verdad y los
combinamos más bien tomamos estos
orbitales y los combinamos para hacer
cuatro orbitales híbridos sp3 ahora en
este caso sólo tenemos un carbono con
una unión a tres átomos y agua tres
distintos átomos verdad así que sólo
vamos a necesitar tres de estos
orbitales vamos a promover digamos este
orbital ese vamos a ponerlo
vamos a promover este orbital ese y aquí
tenemos el orbitales y vamos a bajar
sólo dos orbitales p muy bien aquí vamos
a tener sólo dos orbitales p muy bien
tenemos dos orbitales p y por supuesto
va a quedar sólo un orbital p digamos
por acá arriba verdad ese orbital p no
está hibridado ok entonces cada uno de
estos orbitales tiene un electrón ok
vamos a ponerlo así tenemos este este
éste
y este ahora bien este orbital ese ya no
es un orbital ese verdad ahora es un
orbital sp2 lo mismo ocurre para cada
uno de estos orbitales son orbitales sp2
y son sp2 justamente porque son un
híbrido de un orbitales y dos orbitales
p y esto es justo a lo que le llamamos
hibridación sp2 y déjenme ponerlo por
acá arriba con un color distinto tenemos
una hibridación sp2 verdad ahí lo
tenemos y eso es porque nuevamente
estamos usando un orbitales y dos
orbitales para nuestros nuevos orbitales
híbridos así que este carbono que
tenemos de aquí tiene una hibridación
sp2 y lo mismo podemos decir para este
carbono que tenemos acá verdad
ambos tienen hibridación sp2 y algo que
todavía hay que remarcar es que tenemos
un orbital pequeno esta hibridado verdad
eso eso hay que considerarlo cuando nos
fijemos en
geometría de nuestras moléculas así que
si hacemos un poquito más de espacio
vámonos un poco más abajo ahora nosotros
sabemos que los orbitales s digamos
tienen como una figura de tipo esférico
verdad entonces tenemos un orbital ese
que es más o menos de este estilo y
tenemos dos orbitales p verdad tenemos
dos orbitales p que los orbitales que
tienen como esta forma del lóbulo verdad
más o menos y si nosotros vamos a hacer
híbridos a partir de éstos pues vamos a
tener 33 híbridos verdad digamos más o
menos como con esta forma donde tiene un
lóbulo más más grande que el otro verdad
ahí lo tienen y como hemos estado
haciendo en los vídeos anteriores cuando
estemos dibujando la digamos las
moléculas y todas nuestras imágenes
vamos a ignorar este pequeño lóbulo que
tenemos por abajo ok entonces esto nos
dan nuestros orbitales híbridos sp2 y en
términos del porcentaje digamos de las
características que pueden tener pues
como
tenemos uno un único orbital ese uno de
tres pues vamos a tener un 33% de
características del orbital s mientras
que como tenemos dos orbitales que vamos
a tener alrededor del 67 por ciento de
características de orbital p y por
supuesto tenemos más más características
s en un orbital híbrido sp2 que en un
orbital híbrido sp3 verdad y como la
densidad electrónica en un orbital s
está mucho más cerca del núcleo okay
podríamos pensar digamos en este de aquí
podríamos entonces pensar que este
lóbulo que tenemos aquí es un poquito
más corto con la densidad de electrónica
estando mucho más cerca del núcleo que y
eso va a tener un efecto en la longitud
de los enlaces es verdad que vamos a
estar formando así que vamos a continuar
y vamos a dibujarla y digamos la
molécula del etileno o del dt no ok
vamos a hacer más espacio
ahí está
nosotros sabemos que cada uno de estos
carbonos que tenemos en la molécula del
té no verdad tiene una hibridación sp2
verdad eso significa que cada carbono va
a tener tres orbitales híbridos sp2 así
que vamos a tratar de dibujar esto
tenemos un carbono verdad y tenemos tres
orbitales híbridos aquí tenemos uno acá
vamos a tener otro y finalmente un
tercero verdad y solo para irnos
acordando déjenme repetir en la
estructura de puntos del eterno
tienen aquí tienen sus cuatro hidrógenos
verdad entonces ahí están y recordemos
que estos dos están unidos verdad
entonces si ponemos nuestro segundo
carbono aquí tenemos un enlace por aquí
un enlace perdón
tenemos un orbital híbrido por aquí
vamos a tener otros dos tenemos otros
dos orbitales híbridos y por supuesto
cada uno de estos orbitales tiene un
electrón verdad aquí tenemos uno para
este orbital y otro para este orbital un
electrón y un electrón además sabemos
que cada uno de estos carbonos tienen un
orbital p verdad tenemos un orbital p
déjenme ponerlo con otro color tenemos
este orbital p verdad ahí está el
orbital t para este carbono y un orbital
p para este otro carbono muy bien y
ahora lo único que nos falta es además
de ponerle su electrón a cada uno de
estos orbitales pues además es agregar
los hidrógenos
tenemos hidrógenos que están uniéndose
con los carbonos entonces tienen
un hidrógeno dos hidrógenos tres
hidrógenos
y 4 hidrógenos verdad eso corresponde a
estos hidrógenos que tenemos en la
estructura de puntos y por supuesto
estos hidrógenos los representamos con
su orbital s verdad entonces cuando
repasamos muy bien la figura vemos que
tenemos algunos traslapes en los
orbitales verdad por ejemplo aquí
tenemos un traslape otro tras la t3
traslapes 4 traslapes y 5 tras látex
verdad entonces esto como vimos en el
vídeo anterior significa que tenemos
cinco enlaces sigma verdad y si nosotros
los queremos representar en la
estructura de puntos tenemos dos tres
cuatro
5 sin embargo nosotros de la estructura
de puntos sabemos que tenemos una
configuración distinta verdad tenemos un
enlace doble entonces aquí lo que nos
está represan representando perdón es
que tenemos un traslape y podríamos
decir lo que es un traslape lado al lado
entre estos orbitales p que no tenían
más que su electrón verdad y esto se
traslapan tanto arriba como abajo verdad
esto es lo que vamos a llamarle un
traslape lado al lado de nuestros
orbitales p y esto lo que crea es un
enlace para que un enlace pi que se
representa con nuestra letra griega y
que se dice simplemente pi verdad y éste
traslape lo que va a prevenir una
rotación libre de esta molécula verdad
cuando cuando estemos fijándonos en el
ejemplo de él
cuando estábamos observando el ejemplo
del etano teníamos una rotación libre
alrededor del enlace sigma que conectaba
a los dos carbonos pero debido a que
tenemos
en la cep y aquí entre estos dos
carbonos ok como tenemos este enlace y
esto va a prevenir las rotaciones así
que no vamos a obtener distintas
conformaciones para la molécula del té
no aunque no tenemos rotación libre
vamos a escribir eso no hay rotación
libre en el espacio y eso se debe a este
enlace
verdad así que cuando tengamos un doble
enlace uno de esos enlaces es un enlace
sigma y el otro enlace es un enlace p
entonces tenemos cinco enlaces sigma y
tenemos un enlace y ahora si nos
concentramos por ejemplo en la longitud
o la distancia entre estos dos carbonos
déjenme marcarlos con otro color digamos
este carbono y este carbono verdad si
nos concentramos en la distancia entre
estos dos carbonos resulta ser de
aproximadamente 1.34 and sons
si recuerdas la distancia entre los dos
carbonos en la molécula del etano verdad
la distancia entre ellos era de
aproximadamente un 1.54 amstrong este
doble enlace va a acortar la distancia
entre estos dos carbonos muy bien y eso
lo puede uno pensar justamente porque
hemos incrementado las características
es verdad hemos aumentado las
características s de estos orbitales
híbridos recordemos también que aumentar
la característica de esa s perdón
significa que la densidad electrónica
está mucho más cerca del núcleo y eso va
a ser que este lóbulo verdad se acorte
un poco con la comparación del ejemplo
anterior verdad para el etano vamos a
fijarnos nuevamente ahora en la
estructura de puntos pero ahora vamos a
utilizar la el concepto de número
estético muy bien entonces tenemos
nuestros dos carbonos unidos por un
doble enlace tenemos nuestros hidrógenos
tenemos nuestros cuatro hidrógenos así
que recordemos que el número estético
estaba definido como el número de
enlaces sigma verdad podríamos calcular
el número estético para este carbono
entonces tenemos que calcular el número
de enlaces y gmac que tenemos que en
este caso son 3 recordemos que en un
doble enlace un enlace es sigma y el
otro enlace es pib entonces tenemos 3
enlaces igna y hay que sumarle el número
de parejas solitarias de electrones que
tenemos que en este caso son 0 por lo
tanto el número estético para ese
carbono es 3 y lo mismo podríamos decir
para este otro carbono así que
necesitamos 3 orbitales híbridos y hemos
visto en este vídeo que tres orbitales
híbridos sp2 forman digamos lo que
estamos trabajando de la hibridación sp2
así que si tenemos un número estético de
tres tenemos que pensar en hibridación
sp2 verdad entonces estos dos carbonos
de aquí tienen una hibridación sp2
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo digamos él
vamos a hacer el triple tree fluoruro de
boro muy bien entonces esto simplemente
en su fórmula molecular es bf3 verdad
boro y 33 átomos de flúor entonces si
nosotros queremos representar esta
molécula podríamos ponerlo de esta forma
tenemos el boro unido a tres átomos de
flúor
y esta verdad y tenemos que completar
los objetos de cada uno de estos átomos
de flúor verdad entonces tenemos algo
así bueno
y finalmente ponemos los de este átomo
de flúor muy bien entonces si ahora
queremos calcular el número estético
para el boro tenemos el número estético
es igual al número de enlaces sigma que
en este caso son tres y hay que sumar el
número de parejas solitarias de
electrones que en este caso son cero
entonces tenemos un número estético de
tres y eso nos indica que este foro
tiene una hibridación sp2 si nosotros
nos aventuramos a representar esto pues
vamos a tener nuestro átomo de boro que
está unido a los tres átomos de flúor
muy bien ahí tenemos estos tres átomos
pero además el boro va a tener un
orbital no híbrido de un orbital p que
no está hibridado verdad entonces vamos
a ponerlo por ejemplo
por aquí y esta sería una representación
de nuestra molécula y algo que hay que
considerar cuando trabajamos con el boro
es que solo tiene 3 electrones de
valencia verdad a diferencia del carbono
que tiene 4 así que cuando pensamos en
sus orbitales híbridos digamos aquí
tenemos un orbital sp2 otro orbital sp2
y tiene otro orbital sp2 y finalmente
tiene un orbital p entonces sus 3
electrones de valencia van a ocupar
estos orbitales ok mientras que el
orbital pp va a estar vacío así que
cuando nos regresamos a esta imagen este
orbital
este orbital p en realidad está vacío y
eso significa que puede aceptar una
pareja de electrones cuando estamos
pensando esto en términos del
comportamiento químico una de las cosas
que puede hacer el df 3
digamos este este boro puede aceptar una
pareja de electrones y funcionar como un
ácido de louis verdad y esa es una forma
en la que podemos pensar cómo es que
digamos la hibridación nos permite
pensar algo más allá de la estructura y
cómo es que podría reaccionar verdad
este boro resulta ser o más bien resulta
tener una hibridación sp2 lo cual
significa que podríamos hablar también
de la geometría de esta molécula verdad
está la geometría de la molécula es
tribunal plana verdad si nosotros por
ejemplo podríamos pensar que estos tres
átomos de flúor forman un triángulo
verdad es decir podríamos pensar que
esto se encuentra sobre un mismo plano
muy bien y bueno decimos que es
triangular justamente por la figura que
forman estos átomos de flúor y de hecho
el ángulo entre estos entre digamos
entre dos flúor pasando por el boro
es de aproximadamente 120 grados y eso
es muy fácil de explicar porque si tú
pones el bromo digamos en el perdón el
boro en el centro ok y tienes tus tres
átomos de flúor y pintas digamos un
círculo y el círculo tiene 360 grados al
dividirlo entre tres cada uno de ellos
será de aproximadamente 120 grados en el
próximo vídeo vamos a hablar de la
hibridación esp